Hi, I'm Sharon Katsky, and I'm the president of Vism White, and I have the pleasure today of
speaking with Dr. Kevin Connors with the Connors clinic. We're going to talk about some of the
ways that we can support people with cancer, and the course that he actually has. So Dr. Connors,
I'm going to let you run with that. Oh, well, thank you. Yeah, we do have a course based upon
my book Stop Biting Cancer and Star Treating the Cause. I've been seeing people with a cancer
diagnosis since the late 90s. I've been out of school since, let's see, I graduated in 1986.
So I've been around a long time, and I wrote a book. I think I wrote the first edition back in 2010
or 12 or something like that, and I think it's on the third or fourth edition right now. Stop
Biting Cancer and Star Treating the Cause, and we've had tens of thousands, if not a hundred thousand
downloads, it's on Amazon and available for everybody. But I thought, you know, the last edition is
up to like 600 pages, and I thought nothing's about two years ago. We need to make a course out of this
and make it more digestible for people to get this information, because sometimes some people like
to read and do well with that. But as new things come out, I don't want to just keep publishing new
editions with a course, then we can make that a living course. And as new things come out, I add new
videos and new information to that course, and people can get updates. So we did that. I think we
published the course maybe two years ago, and it continues to evolve and get bigger and bigger,
and more videos, and more helpful diagrams and data that people can use to help deal with a
serious diagnosis like cancer. Right. Well, I'm pleased to offer the course in conjunction with
the Vism light, because you offer the Vism light, and there's a lot of ways that the Vism light
can help through the course of this diagnosis. So when you talk to people, what is the, is there a
number one thing that people have in common besides that they've gotten this diagnosis?
Somebody's got a diagnosis of cancer, you typically, it can be tied to their environment.
It can be tied to their, which part of that has to do with diet. Part of that has to do with
exposure to chemicals. Is it, well, how can a little child have cancer and haven't tied to their
environment? Has it tied to their, to their, to the mother's environment? You know, what was she
exposed to? Medicines that she may had to take on a chemical that she was exposed to in there,
where they live, but what she ate and drank, and those affect our cell. So will we discuss cancer?
We want to make it clear that what cancer is? Cancer is your old cells, and it starts, cancer starts
in one cell, something got inside that cell and disturbed the DNA at the nucleus, and the
replication rate of that DNA. And now that cell is in a state of rapid replication, and it's
replicating cells that are in a state of rapid replication. That's the definition of what cancer is.
That's what makes it difficult for your body to heal sometimes because it is your old cells,
and when your T cells and your natural killer cells that are supposed to destroy enemies comes up
to a cancer cell, well, the cancer cell is your B, your old cell will disable the T cell's ability
to kill it. And so the cancer can continue to grow, renovate it, and continue to replicate.
And that's where you're using frequencies and dietary changes. So you're not continuing to fuel
the cancer, specific nutrition that could be a good, you know, at helping kill cancer cells and
stimulate your immune system. All could be good adjuncts to a person's protocol, whether they choose
to do standards of care or not. Would any of these vibrational therapies or light therapies
make the cancer react in a negative way? Well, the therapies that are typically used by
practitioners, and what I recommend a lot is the frequency medicine. So using rife technology,
using bison light, and I have in favor of using frequencies with light, because I think it has
a different added benefit to people, especially with cancer. Can there be negatives to using
frequencies, light frequencies with cancer? The beauty of it, the easy answer is no, there's none. So
there's zero contraindications, zero for cancer patients. Now I would rephrase that if we were
talking about cancer, so we're talking about tick-borne illness, like Lyme disease. Yes,
there can be contraindications, or we should say concerns when you're using light frequencies
on Lyme disease, because they work. So when you're trying to kill Lyme disease, which is
Orelia, as a gram-negative bacteria, there's other complications. Gram-negative bacteria have
lipopolysaccharides, and they're cell membranes. You can kill too quickly. You'll liberate a lot of
lipopolysaccharides, which are called endotoxins, and you can produce what is known as a herccymer.
Reaction, you can make the person ill because you're killing too quickly. Now, your old cells don't
have that. So if you kill cancer cells quickly, you're not going to get a herccymer reaction.
So that's not going to happen. So there are no contraindications with a cancer diagnosis.
There are contraindications, meaning you have to go slowly with your care with a tick-board illness,
or really any gram-negative bacteria that you're trying to kill, you have to go slowly with that.
But with cancer patients, there's no contraindications with using light frequencies.
And so increasing the blood flow in a patient like that is actually a good thing?
Well, let's clarify that because there are some misunderstandings about blood flow and cancer.
So with what are called solid tumors, which are like a breast cancer or a bone cancer.
The opposite of a solid tumor would be like a blood cancer like a leukemia.
There is no solid tumor that you're trying to deal with. So with solid tumor cancers,
you do not want to increase the production of blood vessels into the tumor.
So some people may in a lay term sense, I don't want to increase the blood flow to the cancer
because that will make it worse. Well, that's not a correct physiological statement.
So in truth, you do want to increase the blood flow to the cancer because that's how,
even if you're doing standards of care like chemotherapy, that's how chemotherapy is going to get
to the cancer cell, that's how you're going to be able to oxygenate a cancer.
That's how you're going to be able to get an immune response to the cancer.
What you don't want to do with solid tumor cancers is increase the growth of blood vessels,
of new blood vessels into the cancer itself. So that's called neo-vascularization. You know what,
increase new vessels growing into the cancer. And so you do want to be careful from a
nutraceutical standpoint, not to do that. So step back a second, light frequencies of any source
does not do that. So light frequencies with the visible light, right frequencies with the right
do not increase VEGF production. So VEGF is a chemical called vascular endothelial growth factor,
which stimulates neo-vascularization. So it stimulates new blood vessels to grow.
That's actually a positive thing for like heart disease. That's a positive thing for people who have
history of strokes. You do want neo-vascularization. You do want VEGF, vascular endothelial growth
factor production. But with cancer, you don't. So you do, from a nutritional standpoint, a lot of
nutritionists don't understand this. You would treat a heart disease patient differently.
And in some cases, in an opposite form, then the way you treat a cancer patient. So cancer patient,
you do not want to give nutrition that will stimulate VEGF production.
Heart disease patient, you do want to. So what are you just to clarify with all the listeners out there?
Number one, light frequencies don't do that at all. So light frequencies are going to increase
VEGF production for a heart patient and help a heart patient in that way. And they're not going to
increase VEGF production in a cancer patient in harmive cancer patient that way. But there's
nutritional supplements that do. And typically those are things that stimulate nitric oxide production.
So nitric oxide is something that's used in nitric oxide stimulators or some
are nutritional supplements that are used a lot in the athletic community. Because the
increased vascularization, it increased flushing. It would be something that would you give to
somebody that has high blood pressure. It's something you'd give to somebody that has
intermittent calonification in the heart. Any type of cardiac issues, somebody you'd give it to
somebody that has history of strokes, that would be a good supplement to use for that. And I have
patients that come to me that went to a nutritionist and they're a cancer patient and they're taking
that stuff and you have to take them off of that state. Because the nutritionist was ignorant
about that. So to clarify, if somebody came to you and they had more than one, maybe they had a
heart issue, but they also have cancer and they maybe have something else going on. The concern
there is how the nutritional portion is applied to that person, not how light therapy or vibrational
therapy is applied to that person. Is that correct? That's exactly correct. So in my point of view,
the cancer trumps the cardiac issue. There's other things you can do for a person's heart
and to help clear blood vessels and things that aren't going to increase the Vege F production
with a cardiac patient that you won't hurt their issue with the cancer, with a solid tumor.
And cancer always trumps any other thing, any other cold morbidity that they have going on. So I
would still treat it in that way. I would still not use nitric oxide supplements and other things
that still... Okay, that brings up a question and I want to address it because I know if people
listening to this are going to go, wait a minute. I thought releasing your nitric oxide is a good thing
and that's what light therapy does and that's why the use of infrared light therapy has become
so popular. So can you explain that a little more? So really if you are not stimulating nitric oxide
production using light therapy, that's really not what's taking place with light therapy.
You don't want to increase new nitric oxide to a person's system if they have a solid tumor.
Now again, there may be nutritionists that disagree with me. I just think it's wrong to increase
the Vege F production with somebody who has a solid tumor. You're going to increase the
vascularization of that tumor and thereby have a possibility. It's not always going to happen but
you have a possibility of the tumor expanding and growing because it's because of that. So
that's the general rule of thought with cancer. You don't increase the vascularization
of new blood vessel growth in a solid tumor. Now again, none of this applies to a leukemia
but it applies to anybody with a solid tumor. Okay, and so light therapy use of infrared light
releasing nitric oxide is different than adding new nitric oxide into the system. That's correct.
Yeah, you're not increasing the vascularization, the new growth of vessels in the tumor.
Thank you. That's very helpful to clarify on that. And so when we're using
vibrational therapy or tools like you're right or the business line, I would love to talk about how
we can help people by using the Vizlum light in this entire process.
Well, I'm a huge fan of anybody's read any of my stuff about light therapy because that's how
really I got started in this pathway. I've seen, you know, one of my first patients that
had a cancer diagnosis was, was, you know, a history of my history of doing some studying on light
therapy and then a cancer patient came into my office and I thought, oh my gosh,
this is going to be perfect. We purchased a right machine for her, started doing it.
She was given three months to live. She lived in other 12, 13 years. So it works. It's not a
magic one. It doesn't heal everybody's sickness, but it is another tool. And just like any tool,
like nutrition is a tool. Your, your, you know, spiritual attitude, emotional attitude is a tool,
changing your lifestyle as far as diet is a tool, changing your lifestyle as far as chemical exposure
is a tool. Standards of care and chemotherapy and radiation and surgery are tools. So you want to
use them properly and you want to, you know, use them in combination because the more tools that you
use that are going to work on different facets of your health, you know, the better outcome,
it just makes sense, the better outcome you have. So it's just, you know, you hear people that are
like, oh, I don't want to do any alternative care. I'm just going to do it when a collegeist says,
well, they may or may not have good results. But there's people on the other side of the spectrum
that are, I don't want to do anything with an oncologist. I'm just going to do alternative.
I think there's wisdom in combining as many things as you can wisely. It's not always wise to do
chemotherapy. It's not always wise to not do chemotherapy. But you don't do something just because
you think that's your only option. I think that's why I created the course. That's why I wrote the book
because I think knowledge is powerful when it's properly applied. So you have to have that knowledge
then to then properly apply any of it. So you have to gain knowledge and be willing to do the work
to learn about how to best take care of yourself and your family members so that you can,
you know, pray about how to apply that knowledge. I think that application of that knowledge
really is wisdom. So when we put our lives in the hands of a doctor, whether it be an alternative
doctor or a standard doctor, and just say, well, just you, you cure me, you heal me, you do everything
that you're supposed to do. I think there's danger that I think you you you're headed over some of that
you know, personal responsibility that I think we're supposed to have been carried for ourselves.
It's a scary time for people. Absolutely. The unknowns I do know a person, you know, close to me
and it's very frustrating because the doctors don't agree. So she's getting, you know, different
information from different people. How do you know which way to go? How do you know the right way
to pursue? It's a scary time and anxiety is really, really high, which is why
the green light in here on the anxiety setting is a really helpful tool for people while they are
trying to sort through this process. If your body's not in a parasympathetic state,
the rest and digest, and instead it's in the fight or flight state, you can't heal. Your your
body is so, so tight and so in that fight mode that you can't heal. So keeping yourself in parasympathetic
mode is so important through the whole entire process, and I know that's a big task of people,
but it's really, really important. Well, you're touching on something there that's really I think
the most overlooked piece of the puzzle with not just cancer but with any product disorder.
Nutritionists are looking at, you know, the nutrition of the diet and supplements and such, and I think
it's important we have to do that. But that's really chemistry, right? That's body chemistry.
You're changing chemistry. The oncologist or the standard medical doctor is giving drugs,
chemotherapy, that or radiation. That's really altering chemistry again. It's so easy to overlook
the neurology. So the neurology of everything is that's what actually produces your own chemistry,
is you have to have a nerve input to that cell in order to produce digestive enzymes for the
pancreas or to produce HDL for the stomach, etc. Every cell has a neuronal input to it. And when we're
talking about healing and your immune system to your detoxification pathways to dealing with your emotions
and anxiety and balancing neurotransmitters, the part of the immune system that does that is what you
touched on the autonomic nervous system. And the autonomic nervous system, as you're starting to say,
is separated into two parts, the sympathetic and the parasympathetics. Now these are happening
without you thinking about them, you don't have to think about heartbeat, you know, stomach digest,
liver, you don't even know any of the physiology. This is taking place at an unconscious level.
And we do live in a sympathetic, overdrive world. Our parasympathetics are suppressed, our
sympathetic are overdrive. Now you're going to stimulate much more glutamate production, which is
going to stimulate anxiety and inability to think clearly. Your sympathetic are your fight to
reflect or freeze mechanism. You're going to have a lot of freeze going on when you hear that you
have a cancer serious diagnosis. And it's going to be difficult to think and remember and to process
things, you have to stimulate your parasympathetics to calm that down. You can take some adaptogens to
help with balancing that. You can do some things to change the chemistry of your sympathetic
and parasympathetics. But the best thing to do is to do some parasympathetic exercises
and use light is so important. And so important, easy. My personal favorite is to put blue and green
on together, which gives turquoise to the eye. And when I think about turquoise, I kind of think about
sitting on a chair on the beach with the waves blowing on me. I'm talking about it and I'm going
into parasympathetic state. Look at what is happening with my nose. I'm fighting back a
yawn right now. And I don't even have a light on. That's how powerful that can be because I've
done it so much. It's sort of a Pavlov dog theory. My body's like, oh, I know what's coming. Okay,
I start salivating, you know. And that's how quick the autonomic function as well. Just what you
just mentioned. And everybody can attest to it as if you're driving your car and you hear a siren
behind you. You know, you instantly, your blood pressure jumps up 10 points and you instantly
get that just that little scared feeling. That's how fast your nervous system works.
And we can get stuck in that in that fear mechanism and anything you could do to to calm down
the sympathetics and stimulate the parasympathetics is so powerful to your healing. I mean, we
could talk for literally an hour, the chemistry effects of the parasympathetics. Parasympathetics
control your immune response. That is what controls B cell and T cell response are your parasympathetics.
If your parasympathetics are in the dumps, you're not going to be able to fight a serious disease.
You're going to have a decreased white blood cell code. Your parasympathetics control your
detoxification pathways. They control your gut botility issue. So you're not going to be detoxing.
You're not going to be creating good enzymes by your liver phase one and phase two and phase three
detox pathways. If you have, if you're stuck in a sympathetic older drive. So this is so important.
It is. And you just touched on the detoxing. And that is also important. And I know you talk about
this in your course, which is a phenomenal course. And I've really encouraged people that are in this
process to get involved in this course. But you talk about how detoxing isn't a one and done.
I mean, we can't go through a little detox program. We need to be detoxing every day. This is a life
thing. And we do it in our guy. We do it however we want to do it. But if it's part of our daily
routine, then it doesn't feel so much like a detox. It's more of just part of our wellness routine.
And you don't need to go through a big detox period. Is that correct then?
Right. I'm not a big fan of the detox box detox things because you need to be supporting your
detox pathways all the time. It doesn't mean you need to be taking a bunch of supplements. But you need
to be understanding how those pathways work. And you need to be supporting those issues that
the phases of detox that you might have personal issues with. And as you understand those phases of
detox that you might go, oh yeah, I have really bad gall bladder issues. I really need to support
with that one. Or yeah, I'm constipated a lot. I need to figure out how to fix that and support that.
Or what it is that your personal issues are. Because if you're not getting dealt what is on the inside,
you are becoming toxic. And so that's so, so important to keep the body in the digestive and the
microbiome and all of that moving in a right way. And that's really something that isn't even in
a lot of people's mind. What goes in comes out and some of it stays stuck. And so how can we help
them with that? Well, one way with the light is we use the yellow. And that's the combination of red
and green. And then the eye sees the yellow. That's the beauty of this light when we can start combining
these colors. And then we put it on our belly button and that belly button and just hold it there.
Just sit there for 10 minutes. How easy can it be while you're talking to somebody or watching
TV or doing anything else? Put the light on your belly button for 10 minutes. I would pick one of
the NOSIA frequencies that we have a chart that we, you know, we offer people. That one cellular
health and vitality is the first thing that comes to my mind, which is frequency A. So you can pick
that. You've got all of those different frequencies in this light and the color combinations in the light
to talk to help support your immune system, your detoxification, and your person pathetic. And that's
all just on the front end. But if you're going through it and you wind up with
side effects from chemotherapy or you're, you know, you got bruising and you got pain from
from the injections and different things like that, the light can help with that too. So between
the course and the light, you've got a great package of support and we're here to help.
It's not it's not a pleasant time for anybody that has no doubt. But I like what thing you touched
out as the ease because I know that people don't follow through with something that's complicated
and difficult and life disrupting the more life disrupting it. So if it's easy to use and
easy to apply the chance that the person is going to use it, it's going to be a much higher
percentage. And you see the results, you know, that's really what you start to see the results
and you start to feel better and you notice your bowel movements are better, you notice your
gut feels better, your inflammation is down, your pain is down. Your energy is up a little bit,
you know, you're not feeling like you had to take that nap every afternoon. And the other thing is
I'm available for a free 30 minute consultation with anybody that gets a light, whether you get it
from us or from the chronic clinic, wherever you get that light, you know, you let us know and we are
here to help you. So we get you started off, right? That's the best way to get you going.
We want you to use the light. The only time it doesn't work if it's over there on the shelf, you know. Right,
right. Well, I thank you for everything you're doing. It's such a blessing to so many people.
Well, I appreciate that. And I appreciate, you know, our partnership. And I'm looking forward
to supporting the course and getting that in more people's hands as well because it's really
important that people know that they've got support and they've got resources that are unbiased
and they're not coming at them from one way or another. It's just like, here's information. Use it.
Right. Information's power. Like you said, knowledge is power. So, so thank you again. I really,
really appreciate it. Absolutely. Thanks for having me on.